this is going to be somewhat of an
easier talk I've got some stories to
share this is about my time at gitlab
leading the data team there and
um yeah I think I think you'll walk away
hopefully with some some lessons and
we'll just Dive Right In
my name is Taylor Murphy I'm currently
at miltono as the head of product and
data previously I was at gitlab I was a
data engineer there data team lead
manager and then also a staff data
engineer as well I was there for about
three years before we spun meltano out
this talk is about lessons that I
learned at gitlab from gitlab that I
think are valuable regardless of the the
culture that you're in and I
specifically say regardless of the
culture because gitlab if you don't know
much about it it has a very strong
culture especially around the time that
I was joining they were becoming a much
bigger company and were well known for
for their culture in particular that's
one of the reasons why I joined that's
why a lot of people joined gitlab so the
the culture of gitlab is really strong
this is a image that they used to have
in their handbook I don't think they
quite use it anymore but it's helpful
for describing the core values of the
the company so the values spell credit
um collaboration results efficiency
diversity inclusion iteration and
transparency and these kind of build up
into this this pyramid that All Leads
towards results and they have little
blurbs there that you can read
all of this this leads to a very unique
culture driven a lot by by the CEO
um one thing about gitlab that a lot of
people know is that we're we're
extremely public about everything we had
a public handbook that you can go read
and many folks probably in the database
have seen parts of the data team
handbook uh all of our merge requests
for the most part are
open in public and you can go see
changes that we're proposing the
conversations that we're having and then
even more crazy is meetings still to
this day a lot of them are live streamed
on YouTube you can go watch them
there's conversations with the CEO I
remember one he was talking to somebody
on Hacker News and said hey let's hop on
a live stream and they talked about
something from a Hacker News thread so
just very public very open
um and very very transparent which was
always exciting for me
another unique aspect of the the gitlab
culture is that every employee knows how
to open an issue make a merge request
and edit yaml and markdown this enables
you to do some really interesting things
like have everything in Version Control
but it's it's something that um I
haven't seen many places elsewhere and
it takes some time like training to kind
of unwind your brain just like oh like
everybody can make a merger class no not
everybody can I get a lot everybody
could and that did enabled some cool
things
another more fun facts about the culture
um pre-covered I'm pretty sure it was
the largest all remote company we were
known for that hiring globally very
asynchronous first culture
um and this culture was reinforced by
the the CEO and the executives quite a
bit so that's gitlab's culture generally
um this talk is going to be kind of
about three key lessons
um simple to say leadership and strategy
matter transparency is is powerful
people and your tools matter
um like I said these are simple lessons
um and I'm kind of a big believer in
like doing the simple things well
repeatably
um and practicing them um and I would
say that each of these are essential to
have in any part of a culture but
they're not sufficient they're not all
the elements of a company culture that
you would want to have
okay so I need to set the stage a little
bit um so I joined gitlab in 2018 and I
am a sad report that was five years ago
that's half a decade uh yeah if you
haven't done the math it makes me sad
2018 facts um you would have been at
data end conf not data Council yes
back in the good old days DBT was
inversion at 0.9.1 we were active users
of DBT at that stage very fun very wild
snowflake was only valued at a measly
1.5 billion dollars and uh our boy root
and tootence lootman was not CEO yet we
still had Bob muglia there and then
generally the the data startup landscape
was was just very different
uh 2018 facts about gitlab they just
raised a series C I think for like 20
million dollars which seems like a small
series
now about 200 people when I joined and
then like I said it was all remote
in 2021 when we spun out multano they by
that time they had 6X the head count at
least to 1200 1500 I think the data team
was still less than 10 people we were a
very small data team for the the size of
the company and the work that we were
doing and we went IPO in in late 2021
and I was part of the team that kind of
built all the metrics and stuff for that
okay so so diving in um we're talking
about you know why leadership and
strategy matters this is a chart that
you can find in the handbook today I
actually just screenshotted it that kind
of gives you an overview of the
hierarchy of an organization I find this
to be very useful because it it shows
you okay what are the different levels
for people within an organization what's
their kind of scope of impact what do
they think about
um and then what are they expected to do
and you can probably find yourself on
there there somewhere if you're a
director you know CEO or an intermediate
whatever
um and it's a nice model to think about
how you affect a change in an
organization
um oh uh by the way that all these
things are linked um if you go to
meltano.com
2023 you'll find the links and you can
directly go to that stuff
so I'm showing this um because when I
was hired I was actually hired as a data
engineer
um just straight a bit engineer I was
reporting to the senior director of data
analytics who we reported up in into the
the CFO in finance
um very soon after I joined I didn't
know this when I joined uh he left the
company and I was directly reporting to
the the CFO which is not a fun place to
be uh it's not the right level of
abstraction
um and you can kind of see this this Gap
that existed very quickly I became the
manager of the team because I had
managed teams previously and I was able
to hire a data engineer and a data
analyst but what I want you to notice
from from this hierarchy is there's a
big gap and this this director graph
that was a problem it would become a
problem
um
as we were scaling from for me in
particular for the data team I think it
caused some interesting challenges and
then also I think reporting into Finance
was a problem not saying that like data
teams shouldn't report into Finance but
it creates interesting challenges
um this combination of not kind of
having director level leadership
particularly in in 2018
um reporting into Finance uh led to
having kind of a lack of leaders data
leadership across the organization
within Finance we were doing well but
having that influence across the
organization just just a lack of power
like I didn't have that influence I
could manage my team and have some
influence across other teams I just
didn't have much power in the
organization
it also led to a lack of situational
awareness when you're not in the room
where some of these conversations are
happening even for a very transparent
company like gitlab you just aren't
aware of certain things that are
happening you can only consume so much
information and this led to us really
underserving product marketing sales
customer success engineering like
literally everybody but Finance was
unhappy with our output maybe you're in
a similar situation I mean I think the
the data needs of an organization always
kind of outstrip capabilities
so I want to share um story time I want
to share two quick stories kind of about
uh strategy uh without leadership and
then leadership without strategy and
this kind of leads to the you know
strategy and leadership are important
so some some strategy no leadership
if you look in the the handbook today
you'll see this image on the data team
Handbook of like these are all the data
program teams and you know I think
there's 10 and 11 of them there
and there's also this nice image of
um there's a central data team and then
there's all these you know hubs hubs and
spokes
and in the handbook it looks it looks
really nice it looks like we planned
this out and it's well structured
that wasn't the case
um what what really happened was data
was doing the best that we could and
then you see that somebody's getting
onboarded and their title's marketing
analyst you're like oh that's
interesting let's set up a coffee chat
with this person and see what's going on
uh marketing hired their their own
analyst and well then didn't necessarily
consult us
didn't necessarily have to
um but it would have been nice I'm
picking on marketing here so the the
direct story is that they wanted to
implement pendo pendo's a product
Analytics tool maybe they call
themselves a platform now I don't know
100 what they do we never actually
implemented it but marketing loved it
um problems that we had though it's uh
well for them you know it's all their
problems uh the marketing leader had
previously used it before and they were
just ready to go like they had they knew
what they were doing and they were
wanting to put this in place
uh the data team we come in and we're
like uh wait
um this is not open source
um it's unclear how we're going to get
the data out of this system what's
generating it um like what additional
reporting you want to want from it
um and just generally we weren't kind of
consulted or informed in this decision
and we started to push back pretty hard
on this
um we
pushed for for snow plow the data
analyst on my team she'd used it
previously and was like look like you
don't need pendo this is going to be
more aligned with our values it's open
source here's what we can do for it and
in the end
um we won but uh
I don't know if still to this day if it
was 100 the right decision I think you
know we likely over promised as a small
data team the marketing team knew what
they were trying to do and we had kind
of our own internal strategy of like
this is a open source product and we
want to bring everything into the data
warehouse
um and I think you know potentially wood
better visibility across the
organization have helped us and
potentially led to a different outcome
maybe uh it's hard to say but when
you're coming into a meeting with
um you know some Executives in the data
team uh not having anybody like at the
director level that's able to advocate
for data can be a challenge
um and then also like I'm just not sure
we made a ton of friends from that in
the end we implemented snow plow and we
were able to deliver on some of our
promises but I think it left the the
marketing team somewhat frustrated
mini lessons from this one um you know
hunger Hunger for data doesn't stop uh
at your team's capabilities people want
data um and just because you're telling
them no they're going to try and go
figure it out somewhere else so
something to be aware of
um you know have representation at the
director level uh or above like you need
some power across the org and then just
you know don't report into Finance
the second mini stories is strong
leadership but a minimal strategy so
this is actually the original story of
meltano back then it was called The Biz
Ops project uh meltano at the time was a
very CEO driven project it was the basic
idea was hey everything that we're doing
for software development teams let's do
for data teams one platform work like
software developers this will be great
so when I joined Biz office was kind of
starting to get kicked off we actually
shared a repo for a little while they
had maybe five or six developers I think
on the The Biz Ops project that would
become meltano uh and in August you can
see the the date here August 1st
um we announced that hey data teams
we're working on a tool just for you
uh looking back on it though
um we were for the data team in
particular too focused inward on our own
tooling um today multano is of course a
great tool fantastic we'd love to talk
to you about it but for us at the time
we I didn't have like a very clear
strategy about like exactly what we were
trying to do and how this fit into our
overall strategy for the the company it
was fun don't get me wrong thinking
about our tooling how can we version
control everything how can we build this
awesome tool but it was it was costing
us time in our relationships with the
rest of the organization and leading us
to underserve more so I say here there
was strong leadership from the CEO this
is something he wanted something we were
excited about but our lack of a data
strategy led to again I think
sub-optimal outcomes
that's just what I said yes
um so many lessons from this I think you
know you just have to know what you're
trying to do I just came from obby's
talk with about metric trees which is
like oh man I wish I had something like
that back then to really think about an
anchor
um all the efforts that we're trying to
do as a data team to these metrics and
these outcomes
um and then this is saying the same
thing twice you have to focus and you
just have to know what to say no to
because focusing is how you're going to
be able to get a lot done very quickly
um so yeah so leadership and strategy
matter um I think it helps you have more
context and influence and folks have
talked to me in the past know that I
like to talk about like power within an
organization and I think acknowledging
that power exists and power structures
exist within an org is helpful
um and having somebody with a little bit
of power is always helpful for you as a
data team
um
the strategy it helps you know what to
focus on and when you know how to focus
it's just going to help you be more
efficient so
leadership and strategy matter
second Point transparency is powerful
this is my favorite one so sharing this
slide again transparency was always the
value of gitlab that brought me
to the company and something that I've
pushed on and will continue to push on
for the rest of my career as a reminder
you know we had a public handbook public
merge requests public live streams the I
think we were the first company to
publicly live stream the listing on the
New York Stock Exchange just any excuse
to be public about things
um absolutely was uh was taken advantage
of
and for me transparency like does three
really important things I think it
solves a lot of problems and I'll talk
about that I think it distributes power
which is why I'm a big fan of it I think
it brings more people in
um and I think just generally it's very
efficient
so how does transparency solve problems
uh well it answers a lot of questions so
like if you had a question of what was
the the definition of this this metric
very easy answer it's in the handbook
we've documented it we had a handbook
first culture if uh you didn't know the
answer you need to go put it in the
handbook like immediately
um and that was the case for everything
we would just constantly be sending
links to each other of here's the
definition like go go find it
um
if you had a question what what happened
in that meeting there was always an
agenda and 99 of the time it was either
recorded or it was live stream so you
would get a Google Drive Link or a
YouTube link what's our policy on X it's
it's in the handbook
um this just
was awesome it just solved a lot of
problems um one example that I have here
so these are screenshots from uh merge
request that I made to clarify the
language around gross and net retention
and so you can see on
the right that there's the diff showing
what um what I'm adding what I'm what
I'm deleting here and then there's a
conversation between me and the CFO
um trying to trying to get approval here
he's saying no I don't I don't think he
did this right and then it's cut off but
I'm saying actually I did do it right
and here's my spreadsheet uh
but the nice the nice thing about this
is the merger Quest would be approved by
the stakeholders and then it would get
merged and then you have that full
history of what it what changed what
happened and how how things are
iterating and we would generate tons of
merge requests as we were iterating on
our metric definitions on our DBT models
it would all flow into the to the
handbook
transparency distributes power
um
there's always this extreme visibility
on on policy and definition changes
anytime a company policy changed there
was going to be a merge request there
was going to be an open discussion about
it usually async sometimes we would have
like a sync meeting on that and there's
just the visibility both internally and
externally around what was happening
we had very visible road maps and
backlogs both at the company level but
also on the data team we had our own
issue tracker I had my roadmap orbs is
what we were working on our Milestones
all that fun stuff and it generally made
priority conversations uh easier not
entirely easy but easier and so when
people come to you say like hey I need
to answer this question and say okay
look you know this is this is what I'm
working on help me figure out how to
prioritize this better against all these
other
priorities that I have it just made
those conversations easier to bring that
visibility into the conversation
another another one is is if you could
see the code if you can see the text you
can make a proposal you can make a
change my very favorite example of that
is this merge request that uh the
inimitable Emily shario made to update
our parental leave policy from 12 weeks
to 16 weeks so the actual diff for this
if you were to click changes it's just
one character going from a two to a six
this merge request itself was you know
had lots of information because it
scroll for a while the business case for
it there was internal discussion there
was discussion on the the merger Quest
itself and eventually it was merged and
I was able to take advantage of an
additional four weeks of Parental leave
when I had my my second child
it distributes power it's just really
cool that anybody can make these
proposals a silly example that I don't
have a picture of is a sales guy came
into our company proposed that all sales
people get 600 phones paid for by the
company that was immediately closed by
the CFO uh saying no we're not doing
that
transparency uh is efficient
um when you're transparent I think you
really invite people into the the
process it definitely increases
collaboration
um by by leaning into that value you
just make it more visible and that's why
we love open source too is it's just
visible it brings people in
um it's easier to make changes I think
uh diffs are lovely to to look at and
see what's going to happen and I like
diffs for a lot of things and it does
enable this this asynchronous
communication when you're really
committed to being transparent that
encourages or maybe forces you to have
specific habits around documentation and
recording what's what's being said and
discussed but it also enables you to to
not be blocked by others
so how did this manifest particularly
within the within the data team
basically I just want to Version Control
all the things uh if I'm touching it
interacting with it it needs to be
version controlled and I want every
change to flow via a pull request or
merge requests if you're at gitlab
what this meant for us was that we had
our gitlab data team repo it's at
gitlab.com data analytics uh you can see
we have this was recent so not all these
obviously I touched but like almost 34
000 commits um 10 gigabytes of data I
don't know what's actually in there
um but everything until recently you
could see most of the issues most of the
merge requests um but all the code was
was public and in this single repository
and so it's very cool to be able to to
point people to say hey we're changing a
metric here's the DBT code that's
changing and this is the extract and
load code that's that's driving it
um and it allowed us actually to scale
beyond our means because people from the
outside of our team could actually help
and make changes
of course the data team handbook we had
our SQL style guide or python style
guide DVT style guide in there
documentation about how we use snowflake
permafrost all these different tools
um and something that I'm very proud of
still reference for will likely
reference for the rest of my career we
copied a lot of it when we spun out
meltano and have driven our own handbook
uh and of course all the you know all of
our policies and everything were in
there it also influence our uh tool
choice so this is the old Miltona logo
that we used to have
um but we use you know we use looker
because they had git integration DBT of
course because you could put it in uh
and get in a file system
um we had an internal tool called
postgres pipeline
um which we use to migrate our data from
postgres permafrost was a tool that was
originally with Montana that we spun out
for managing permissions on Snowflake
and then of course we had CI where we
were doing like zero copy clones and all
this really fun stuff to to run
um
DBT and do all these tests before some
of the newer features that the DBT came
out I think the only thing we didn't
Version Control was that the actual data
itself but I think there's some vendors
out there like lakefest that'll help you
do that if you need
um okay One More Story uh so we were
customers of uh looker
um pretty happy uh with with it
generally
um and because we were a very
transparent company there were a lot of
curiosity about how looker worked from
the multano team in particular
and so being the git lab and the company
that we are I'd hop on live streams with
them or we record them and then upload
them to YouTube later and there's lots
of videos of me and other people of my
team like walking them through the
looker interface well how does this work
how does look ml work what's a measure
what's the dimension what happens when
you do x y and z
um and evidently looker saw a lot of
those those videos and started telling
us that we needed to stop that that we
were trying to reverse engineer
um their product but we didn't know at
the time was that they were being
acquired by Google uh and they actually
we had 24 hours notice before they shut
down our looker instance this was we
were using looker for all of our
reporting in the company everybody we
had like a special license where
everybody would have viewer access and
could see all these reports and like
Monday I got a notification hey they're
going to turn it off at like 11 A.M
tomorrow it was like oh uh okay what do
we do so because of like the tool
choices that we had and that the fact
that we used the crap out of DVT
um we were actually able to screenshot
move all our repositories and basically
take a snapshot in time of everything
that was in looker
um before they shut it down and pretty
quickly like spin up essentially re-dash
for a little bit and then go on another
journey to find a tool we wound up using
Periscope data which is now part of
scisense
um
they had a nice Version Control
integration as well that was pretty
important to us I attribute that to like
this value of transparency where because
everything was version controlled
because we wanted to be visible we were
actually able to respond to this crisis
very quickly and uh manage it in a way
that while disruptive and an interesting
War Story
um we were able to move on and kind of
recovered quite nicely but definitely
traumatic for for everyone on the team
for a bit
awesome so uh transparency is powerful
those problems distributes power is
efficient and I think the liquor story
kind of encaptures that nicely
um
oh you can see me trying to use markdown
and it didn't automatically make twos
and threes uh
so kind of mini lessons from this uh
commitment to transparency definitely
requires discipline um but it is really
valuable one interesting lesson having
split out Montano and trying to apply a
lot of these these principles is you
find out where it's easy to do something
in a larger organization versus a
smaller organization and it's led to
interesting conversations internally on
how we have applied the gitlab values
and convert them to kind of Miltona
values transparency does force
conversations and share of power and I
think a really useful way
and brings visibility to problems
especially things that Executives care
about uh and that's something that I try
to bring to to how I run the data team
at Milton
and just acknowledging you know even
with with this transparency that
um while I could force conversations
between certain people I still didn't
have that director level of leadership
until later in my tenure there and so
these power structures still exist and
while there's maybe a merge request
sitting there there are going to be
conversations that happen that you can't
see uh and strategy and Leadership and
having people that can be in the rooms
still matters
all right so that's
that's two lessons uh leadership
strategy matter and transparency is
powerful
my last one is probably the least
controversial one people and tools
matter
so
this is probably the best thing I did as
a manager was hire awesome people uh on
my team so Emily Cheryl sherio many of
you maybe know she's the data analyst on
my team and then Thomas lapiana is a
data engineer and for
almost a year maybe nine months it was
just the three of us as like the the
trio of data team
um and we we've really punched above our
weight
um I think they were very aligned with
with the values of the company
um very skilled professionals and I'm
still very much in in touch with them
today very proud of those two hires uh
but what does it mean to hire
um great people uh one I think you just
need people that obviously can do the
job like if you don't know SQL if you
don't know python that's gonna be a
problem
um so that's kind of the minimum
things that I look for uh you need to be
able to talk to other people I think you
know a lot of data we get wrapped up in
the the tools and the code that we're
writing so much of it is is talking to
other people and encoding knowledge into
computer systems that's why I love data
it's like a representation of reality a
representation of truth and you need
people on your team that can talk and
pull out that information and actually
encode it
other important parts uh dimensions of
hiring great people they really need to
match the stage of the company that
you're in
um I've Heard lots of stories of hiring
somebody from larger organizations into
smaller organizations and there just
isn't that fit where maybe this this
person isn't used to the the pace or
vice versa maybe somebody is is high
energy and wants to get a lot done and
gets they get very frustrated by
bureaucracy you have to figure out how
to kind of match their energy to your
stage as a company and be honest about
like the type of person that you need
and I always look for people that are
just eager and want to learn and grow
yes they they have the skills but
they're not satisfied with being
static where they are I want them to
have that growth mindset and just
curious always curious about what
they're they're trying to do and what
they're trying to learn
and hiring great people is is I think
very important because people reinforce
the culture I think in every moment
um maybe this feels obvious to say but
like culture is kind of a emergent
property of the the patterns and
behaviors of people and if you don't
have good people you're not going to be
able to keep the culture alive in
reinforcement
and this one I don't know if folks agree
with but I I genuinely believe that that
tools
um reinforce your people every time
they're used now I'm not saying if you
use you know Tableau over light Dash or
something like that that your you know
culture is gonna drastically change
um but I think there are elements of
using a tool that that reinforce the
value systems of the people on your team
so One More Story
um that kind of exemplifies this I think
maybe this is common
um figuring out monthly recurring
Revenue in an organization so we had uh
you know as you do disparate systems
doing their own thing engineering has a
customer's database that defines uh like
license Keys Salesforce sales team had
their account hierarchy how everything
rolls up and in Zora where we had
subscription and skew data over time and
the finance team was was managing that
and this uh when you have multiple
systems disparate sets of information
you're trying to figure out a shared
source of truth that's where a data team
I think shines
um sure you can throw a data team at
analyzing problems within one one system
but it's integrating data together uh
that is really where data teams um
are powerful
so us and the data team here this are
our little Trio started lots of
conversations with with folks on these
teams about how do these systems work of
course you do as you do you
pull all the data into the warehouse and
we started of uh of course going back
and forth with these folks via DBT
modeling what we were seeing what they
were
um
uh understanding their systems to
operate
um and the cool thing from this uh I
don't
I actually don't know how common this is
but the fun thing about
um Zora subscriptions as it turned out
they were these were actually a dag uh
through time so we would have we had
multiple customers who had subscriptions
different teams buying gitlab they're
like oh the account team wanted to
actually consolidate this into one team
and then for whatever reason maybe
another team needed to buy it or they
just split them back out and you could
trace over time how these subscriptions
were linking up and then you had to make
all these decisions about well if they
don't pay for one month and then they
reactivate is that churn you just have
all these interesting conversations but
the dag concept was was very cool and
from this this project and there were
many like it uh there were a lot of very
positive outcomes we helped the sales
team to standardize kind of their sales
force account hierarchy we had DBT tests
that would flag like hey you have an
account here that doesn't have an
ultimate parent and they can go fix that
standardized how Zora subscriptions were
linked
um we identified that they were a dag
and we had tests to ensure data
Integrity that they actually were a dag
when they came to the warehouse we
identified a few bad database practices
and the customers DB like no primary
Keys maybe you're overwriting data a
little bit too much like maybe we just
kind of do some appending there
um open some issues around that I
actually don't know if they solved all
that but we at least identified the
issues
um of course there were multiple metric
updates and definitions around this I
showed you the the image of the merge
request earlier in figuring out all of
the
the intricacies of these different
systems we had
encountable uh merge request updates of
like okay hey uh
retention is now needs to be defined by
this because we had like different uh
caveats because of weirdness in the data
um and then they're of course you know
cleaning up all the bad data as you do
as part of a data team but the outcome
of this was a this looks complicated
it's not too complicated
um but we we had kind of built this
system where each of the teams were able
to use tools to to solve their own
problems so you have the the data team
at the bottom we were creating issues in
gitlab and using gitlab to orchestrate
the the work the data was flowing into
the warehouse we were using DBT we
generated some dashboards and Periscope
that sales team the finance team would
go to and that would actually kind of be
their to-do list of like oh we've got
some subscriptions that need linking
they would go back into Zora make their
own tickets to figure it out and if
there were ever any questions about what
the definition of a metric was or what
the process was it was all in the
handbook and it created this this nice
flow and this didn't come you know whole
cloth this wasn't something like a big
waterfall project this was built up over
time with the goal of better
understanding mrr ARR retention all
those important numbers that you need to
care about as a business
so
I highlight that story because
it's one that I'm proud of it's
something that I think drove a lot of
value for the company and I think we did
it in a way that really lived the the
values of the company I had great people
on my team that were able to deliver
good results we did iteratively we did
it with transparency we did it in
collaboration with the rest of the the
teams that we were working with
um and I think we were fairly efficient
about it because the the tools that we
we chose
um
and the tools that we chose I think did
support our values here
um you know big fan of DBT but a lot of
the stuff was in in you know yaml files
and markdown of course everybody used
gitlab at gitlab that's where all our
issues were all of our merger quests and
then folks use Periscope as our bi tool
and uh
I think you know it's it's simple to say
um of course people matter they do
reinforce your culture uh and I you know
we we love to talk about tools
especially at a conference like this but
I do think they they matter and
um the combination of really good people
and great tools can solve some real
problems for for companies and for
organizations
so those are those are my three lessons
uh leadership and strategy matter
transparency is powerful people and
tools matter
the I want you to take these lessons
um and to really just think about how
they apply for your organization
um in your team culture in particular no
matter the the values of the the company
I think you can take these and think
about both in the micro on on your team
how they apply but also within the
organization you can identify oh you
know are we are we missing some
leadership at a data level maybe you're
a data team lead but if you're directly
reporting to an executive and there's
other directors and VPS in the
organization recognize that that Gap
exists how are you going to handle it
what's your strategy around it is there
something that you can do to be more
transparent in the organization I was at
Katie Bowers talk about the kind of
weekly business reviews that's a great
way to bring transparency to the to the
organization is there something you can
do yourself to do that but how can you
influence the the culture more more
broadly
um and so just you know keep them in
mind when you're facing problems they
won't like I said they are uh simple to
say but they're not uh efficient for for
solving all your problems but I think
they are core elements that no matter
where I work
um and no matter who I talk to these are
something things that I will advocate
for in your team and in your
organizations
um so with that uh thank you very much
like I said miltona.com data Dash cancel
2023 there are some links there
um thank you again to Maggie for helping
me with this talk and thank you all for
your time and attention really
appreciate it
[Music]